I know I can earn a living a really good
living about just fighting I know I
could probably earn a really great
living if I added all the extra
curricula stuff and I'm fine with just
having enough yeah Get Enough by just
elbowing keep going to the shadow round
yeah yeah you're not a materialistic
person no you see how I dress yeah I
mean if you want to feel goddamn good at
fighting I usually tell people not to
wear sweats but you can wear sweat stuff
I appreciate it though
I've seen your double leg those sweats
upset
um but you got the dope Jersey on but
you does your family like are they all
the same like where's this from the
black sheep like
my dad and my brother
they're both police officers in Chicago
oh wow they like the gym shoes they like
fancy fancy my dad they like some style
so fashion they're way swagging at me
yeah you dressed us all we were all
standing here you were like what are you
doing here you don't belong yeah I have
the height I have the beard but the
fashion sense no